list Seibert shamed me for taking
antidepressants and yes we need to talk
about it
[Music]
hey everyone it's time to get super
vulnerable and real here in my bed but I
wanted to talk about what happened a few
months ago with Liz and I and also place
it into the context of the broader
conversation around mental health stigma
we are actually days away from Mental
Health Awareness Day on October 10th and
this is really a topic that is near and
dear to my heart because I've got a long
history of mental health struggles so a
little bit of a back story I suffer from
anxiety basically from childhood for
really as long as I can remember my mom
has told me all these stories about me
being so nervous before like doing a
dance competition or recital that I just
would not sleep and this was like when I
was seven and back then most parents
wouldn't have even thought to seek help
or get a diagnosis or really do anything
about it so it actually wasn't until my
late teens that I saw my first therapist
and actually it wasn't even for my
underlying long-standing undiagnosed
anxiety disorder it was because I had an
Ian disorder orthorexia that I had
developed which of course had severe
kind of anxious undertones but yeah
following my enus order recovery I would
say I struggled with pretty severe
generalized anxiety throughout my 20s
and then in my 30s I was diagnosed with
insomnia when I was undergoing fertility
treatments and IVF and you know it just
kind of felt like I was desperately
hopeless in my desire to have tough kids
and then this year I was diagnosed with
ocpd or obsessive-compulsive personality
disorder AKA extreme perfectionism and
also ADHD so that's a lot and I've been
really transparent and vulnerable in
Sharing all of this even though I
definitely know that some people will
automatically now see me as less than or
sick or incapable of doing you know
amazing things with my life Etc but I
really shared these things in hopes of
destigmatizing mental health diagnosis
and also offering some insight into some
of the ways that I've actively were work
to improve my health and life and you
know one of the most profound ways that
I've done this is through medication so
I resisted medication up until like last
year that's 34 years of severe suffering
largely because I was you know afraid of
the stigma or the pill shaming that
often comes alongside taking psychiatric
medication so you know often stigmatized
is like crazy pills or addictive toxins
you know all of these kinds of
antidepressants and other mood
stabilizers have really long been
assigned a really bad rap and not
surprisingly that reputation has often
been transferred to those who take them
in Wellness culture there's this like
common idea that folks who take pills
just like didn't do the work and while I
really do not think there's anything
wrong with medication being a first step
for many people's Journeys for me at
least that could not be further from the
truth I have been a therapy consistently
for over 20 years so I experimented with
a y wide range of modalities including
CBT cbti DBT EMDR hypnotherapy
mindfulness Etc I also have a very well
balanced you know like a brain
supporting diet with little alcohol and
zero recreational substances and I
exercise and meditate daily me taking
medications hasn't been a reason for me
to stop all of these mental health
supporting strategies that I've adopted
over the years but rather medication has
really just allowed all of these
strategies to actually take hold so for
example I was never able to meditate
before I started medicating because
basically my body and my brain just
would never relax and now I can
successfully quiet my mind for a good 10
minutes of the day so that's progress to
me but anyway
mental health medications got me my life
back and if I had only one regret it was
not having the courage to start them
earlier which brings me to the time that
Liz Siebert pill shamed me for using a
medication that quite literally saved my
life let me show you how I eat all of my
food within three to four hours every
day this is a really really bad idea hi
Abby I'm Liz I'm the girl in the video
that you just reacted to I actually used
to be a fan of yours I used to watch all
of your videos on YouTube but once I
really decided that I was going to get
serious about my health mental and
physical I had to stop watching your
videos for a couple of reasons you
started posting videos like this talk
very openly about your use of
antidepressants and your dependence on
pharmaceutical drugs just to sleep and
get through the day I was in that exact
same spot when you started posting those
videos it was clear to me that you were
stuck in the same place that I was stuck
in so for that reason I decided to stop
watching your videos and stop taking
your advice like I'm honestly still so
shocked that someone thought it was a
good idea to post that and you know I'm
clearly not the only one who has taken
aback judging by the comment section and
the countless response stitches that I
have seen on that app but here's the
thing I am well versed and well prepared
for Creator retaliation and criticism I
know that when I critique diet or
Wellness content or advice from a
creator online that Creator is probably
not going to be happy about it
occasionally I get like a truly gracious
comment a response being like thank you
for educating me on this and explaining
I had no idea I will take it down Etc
but more often than not people are
pissed especially people with really big
platforms who have a lot of people
watching and I get it a lot of these
Fringe diets become people's whole
identity they are so sure of the
efficacy of something with zero evidence
to support it just based on their own
anecdotal experience or perhaps they're
trying to sell you something or both
that their diet is basically in their
mind the only good diet so when I come
in there and point out the holes in
their absolute statements they feel
they've been personally attacked even if
the criticism is not personal at all but
this response by Liz was just so
cowardly and below the belt to suggest
that just because I've struggled with
mental health that I can't educate
intelligently on nutrition really just
demonstrates how little the world
understands about mental health you know
it just reinforces the common stereotype
that those who rely on medication to
function optimally are weak or unable to
cope with hard times Etc that they
haven't just put in more time to learn
how to meditate or go on more walks or
cut out all the carbs Etc but this is an
example of pill shaming and it's
actually one of the strongest deterrents
for people continuing treatment for
their mental health poppy needs more
emotional support than I do some days
but yeah the language used in this video
was also remarkable incredibly
stigmatizing you know like to suggest
that I am dependent on psychiatric drugs
to function in the day or to sleep at
night pains those of us who use
medication to support our health as some
kind of addicts I'm sorry but would you
shame someone with type 1 diabetes for
being dependent on their insulin pump to
stay alive would you shame someone with
severe IBD for taking steroids to help
manage their debilitating flares would
you shame someone for going through
chemo to cure their cancer instead of
like just cutting out sugar I would hope
not though as absurd as that sounds I do
see a lot of Fringe Wellness anti-pharma
Health coaches online take this stance
argue with me in the comments but I find
it remarkably unethical and dangerous
when Healthcare Providers allege that
they can cure a chronic disease purely
through diet but that is a whole other
video for a whole other day here's the
thing
every choice we make for our health
comes with some kind of price everything
is a risk benefit analysis sometimes the
risk is financial sometimes it's
physical side effects sometimes it's
like the time in the gym or doing meal
prep sometimes there is a mental or a
social price but even if I felt like
there was great data to support
something like a carnivore diet for
depression and anxiety which by the way
there is absolutely not it would need to
be evaluated against the risk of being
on a carnivore diet we're talking about
the physical risk of lack of fiber and
micronutrients the financial risk of
needing to take 32 supplements a day to
make that up the social risk of not
being able to enjoy a meal with friends
or family more importantly at least for
me the mental risk of being dragged down
into another Ed you know I have
basically accepted that I have some
underlying predispositions here that I
will likely never be able to just fully
cure not through diet not through
therapy not through like prayer or
meditation not even through medication I
now know that my brain just kind of
looks and functions differently than
neurotypical folks and I've got strong
perfectionistic tendencies that I will
probably never fully turn off and
honestly I don't want to like this is
going to sound super cheesy but I really
love who I am this brain even though
it's certainly come with a lot of
challenges my life has pushed me to do
some pretty cool thing I am a great
attentive involved mom I think I'm
really smart and great at the job
despite whatever results Liz fails to
see and I'm the blue that brings so many
of my friends and family together with
all the constant party planning and
events everyone in my circle relies on
me to do all of these things and do them
well because I do and I'm proud of that
so you know a lot of my outward
strengths are probably in a lot of ways
related to my internal struggle and
Medicaid station has allowed me to
utilize my strengths much better without
as much of a personal burden to me Tick
Tock drama aside what I really want you
to take away from this is how damaging
comments like this can be especially
coming from a creator with over a
million followers and never mind the
damage that it could potentially do to
me to whom they were actually directed
but to all of the vulnerable viewers
watching who are struggling with the
shame of getting the help that they need
you know the lack of cultural
conversation around mental health and
effective Mental Health Solutions is
what keeps stigma alive and thriving we
have to talk about this because talking
about shame and stigma takes its power
away you know as researcher brene Brown
says shame cannot survive being spoken
the more influential people talk about
their mental health struggles and their
medication use the more open you know
your neighbor or your workmate or your
friend will feel to open up about their
struggles and now once supportive
non-judgmental conversation may give
someone the courage to seek the help
that they need to change their life and
this can have a very profound domino
effect that could quite literally change
the world less stigma would improve
uptake of supportive Mental Health
Solutions which would prevent kind of an
US versus then mentally around the
healthy and the mentally ill which would
decrease discrimination and
socio-economic disadvantage of getting a
diagnosis and support can we just take a
moment to imagine how much better we
would all likely be doing if we could
make the best health choices for us
without fear of discrimination and
retaliation standing in our way so for
the record I do not give a if people
want to pill shame me I'm not going to
stop taking my pills
Irving me and I'm
all about taking my pills because
I am privileged to have a platform to do
good and I am sure is gonna use it while
I still can and if you're comfortable I
would love if you would show your
support in the comments by sharing your
own mental health Journey even if it
reaches one other person who feels shame
or fear around getting the help that
they need then I do feel like we have
done some important work here again
October 10th is mental health awareness
day so I really do encourage you to
share this video on your socials with
your friends with your family anyone who
you feel could benefit from knowing that
they have your support and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up do not forget to
subscribe and I will see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye Poppy good work
you support me I support you you say
girl
these are some supportive sounds yep